j'en étais où pardon excusez-moi
et donc nous avons maintenant le texte
examiné sur un procure de législation
commission la proposition relative à la
proposition de loi visant à renforcer la
voie des élus au sein du service public
de l'assainissement francilien présenté
par notre collègue madame Martin de
Sidrac qui est présente
qui est là même la ministre bienvenue ce
matin en commission je rappelle aux
collègues que la séance est ouverte à
tous les sénateurs et toutes les
sénatrices toutes les sénatrices et tous
les sénateurs y compris ce n'appartenant
pas à la commission des lois mais qu'en
revanche le vote est réservé aux uniques
commissaires aux lois voilà
bien madame
la parole à l'auteur du texte madame de
sidac
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre madame la
rapporteur cher Catherine mes chers
collègues la proposition de loi que j'ai
déposée vise à renforcer la voix des
élus locaux au sein du syndicat inter
départemental pour lasainissement de
l'agglomération parisienne communément
appelée le SSIAP avant d'expliciter
davantage le sens de ce texte je tiens à
revenir brièvement sur quelques éléments
de contexte relatifs à l'assainissement
francilien certains d'entre vous le
savent déjà le SSIAP a été créé en 1970
par les quatre départements de la petite
couronne parisienne Paris les
Hauts-de-Seine le Val-de-Marne et la
Seine-Saint-Denis il exerce de manière
dérogatoire aux droits communs la
compétence assainissement pour ces
quatre territoires regroupant près de 9
millions d'habitants
depuis sa création il a également étendu
son champ d'action via des conventions à
187 communes des départements du reste
de l'Île-de-France toutefois ces
communes ne participent pas à la
gouvernance du SSIAP pas plus que les
départements dans lesquels elle se situe
or au cours des dernières années les
élus locaux de mon département les
Yvelines ainsi que ceux du Val d'Oise
ont été témoins d'incidents majeurs
survenus au sein de la station
d'épuration dite de senaval cette usine
la plus grande d'Europe a notamment
connu un incendie en 2019 et plus
récemment en octobre 2022 une fuite de 4
tonnes de biogaz les élus locaux n'ont
pas été informés de ces incidents ou
avec retard et de manière parcellaire
l'absence d'un circuit efficace
d'information à l'égard des élus locaux
crée nécessairement de l'inquiétude
parmi les habitants des communes
concernées
à la suite du dernier incident d'octobre
2022 les services préfectoraux ont
justement pointé plusieurs défaillances
dans la sécurité des équipements de
l'usine de senaval et seul la préfecture
des Yvelines a mis en place une instance
de dialogue et de suivi avec le SSIAP et
les élus locaux vous comprenez que cette
situation est inadmissible pour les élus
locaux concernés cette absence de
contrôle et de regard par ces derniers
sur les installations du SSIAP ne leur
permet pas d'exercer pleinement leur
mandat des lieux local d'être un relais
pertinent auprès de leurs habitants et
de les rassurer le cas échéant
l'objectif de la proposition de loi vise
très justement à remédier à ces
difficultés les élus locaux des communes
qui disposent d'une station d'épuration
sur leur territoire où se trouvant à
proximité doivent être associés à la
gouvernance du SSIAP et être mieux
informés des décisions prises par cet
instant notamment en matière de gestion
des risques
mes collègues et moi proposions
initialement de permettre aux communes
disposant d'une station d'épuration sur
leur territoire où se trouvant à
proximité de pouvoir sier avec voie
délibérative au conseil d'administration
et au bureau du siècle cependant les
échanges fructueux et constructifs avec
notre collègue rapporteur Catherine
belretti que je salue et remercie ont
notamment mis en avant que la rédaction
actuelle de la proposition de loi
pouvait faire l'objet de certaines
améliorations il est apparu nécessaire
de ne pas créer un déséquilibre au sein
de la gouvernance du ssia à l'heure où
ce dernier assure la mise en oeuvre d'un
important plan baignade vu en vue de la
tenue des Jeux olympiques de 2024 pour
assurer la planification du dispositif
nous avons également réfléchi aux
précisions à apporter pour les communes
ayant un intérêt à siéger au sein du
conseil d'administration du sien
à cet égard le sous-amendement proposé
par notre colonne Jacqueline stage
Brignoud me semble tout à fait opportun
le fonctionnement des stations
d'épuration du ssia ne concerne pas que
les communes d'implantation comme
Saint-Germain-en-Laye mais impacte bien
le quotidien de l'ensemble des communes
qui se trouve autour mais aussi au amant
et on avale de la Seine je m'associe
donc pleinement à la nouvelle définition
proposée elle permettra aux communes qui
ne disposent pas d'une station
d'épuration sur leur territoire de
bénéficier des nouveaux droits créés par
la proposition de loi en se fondant sur
un critère lié au risque plutôt qu'un
critère géographique
enfin l'amendement déposé par la
rapporteur me semble particulièrement
bienvenu en ce qu'il renforce les droits
d'information des conseillers municipaux
tout en leur assurant une voie
consultative au sein du conseil
d'administration du ssia les élus locaux
pourront alors participer lors de la
réunion de cet instance et ils seront en
mesure de faire valoir directement leurs
difficultés tout en obtenant davantage
d'informations sur le fonctionnement des
installations situées sur leur commune
cette nouvelle rédaction apporte donc
une première réponse équilibrée aux élus
locaux des départements de la grande
couronne parisienne qui ne sont pas
outrepeux associés au fonctionnement du
SSIAP de la même manière qui sont peu
informés des événements importants qui
concernent les installations situées sur
leur territoire ou approximité enfin je
profite de cette prise de parole pour
indiquer que les élus locaux des
Yvelines dont je porte la voie
aujourd'hui sont en attente d'un
dialogue beaucoup plus nourri et
régulier avec les instances dirigeants
du SIAP la présidence de cette organisme
interdépartemental ayant changé
récemment il serait intéressant et que
sans attendre les suites de nos travaux
législatifs le SSIAP s'empare rapidement
des difficultés soulevées
une plus grande association des communes
dans les décisions du SSIAP et la mise
en place de nouveaux circuits
d'information à l'égard des communes qui
accueillent ces équipements où se
trouvant à proximité seraient notamment
en situation de crise accueillie très
favorablement par les élus locaux
concernées je remercie une fois encore
notre collègue rapporteur Catherine
belliqui pour la très grande qualité de
son travail et je vous remercie chers
collègues pour votre attention merci
merci
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chère Martha de Sidrac mes chers
collègues cette proposition de loi en
temps répondra à un problème d'une
particulière gravité rencontrée dans le
fonctionnement du syndicat inter
départemental pour l'assainissement de
l'agglomération parisienne SSIAP et ses
relations avec les élus des communes
disposant d'une station d'épuration sur
leur territoire ou situés à proximité
exploitée par le syndicat
cette lacune est apparue de manière
particulièrement criante lors des
différents incidents survenus au sein de
l'usine saine aval et récemment encore
lors de la fuite de quatre tonnes de
biogaz d'octobre 2022 comme l'évoquer
notre collègue à l'instant les élus des
communes des Yvelines et de Val-d'Oise
pointe un déficit sérieux de
communication sur ses accidents leur
ampleur leurs conséquences et leur
solution pour y remédier au surplus ces
usines présentes des nuisances
quotidiennes et des risques importants
pour les habitants des communes
d'implantation ou se trouvant à
proximité vous le savez en matière
d'assainissement la région parisienne
est dotée d'une organisation spécifique
avec un syndicat dont les membres
statutaires sont les départements de
Paris et de la petite couronne
actuellement le seul dispositif qui
associe officiellement les élus locaux à
la gouvernance du ssia et la conférence
d'information annuelle de
l'assainissement de l'agglomération
parisienne prévue par les statues du
Siam elle rassemble sans compétences
délibérative l'ensemble des élus des
communes établissements publics de
coopération intercommunale ou syndicat
des territoires raccordés au ssia par
voie statutaire ou conventionnelle cet
outil n'est pas suffisant pour répondre
aux attentes légitimes en matière
d'information des élus locaux en ce
qu'elles se réunit cannellement et ne
traite pas spécifiquement de la gestion
des sites qui peuvent être sensibles
comme les stations d'épuration cette
situation donc doit évoluer rapidement
car nous le savons bien les élus locaux
sont toujours en première ligne auprès
de leurs concitoyens lorsque de graves
incidents surviennent dans leur commune
il est donc pas acceptable que ces
derniers soient laissés sans information
bien que par la voix de son président le
SSIAP est reconnu que des défauts
d'information ont eu lieu par le passé
et mettent indiquer mener des actions
pour y remédier celle-ci ne saurait
suffire tant l'association des élus à la
gestion des sites situés sur leur
territoire et leur parfaite information
est indispensable et ce dès aujourd'hui
c'est pourquoi l'intention qui anime la
proposition de loi de Martha de Sidrac
qui prévoit de confier aux communes
d'implantations des stations d'épuration
et à celles situées à proximité de
celle-ci un siège avec voix délibérative
au sein du conseil d'administration du
ssia emporte donc ma complète et pleine
adhésion
je vous proposerai néanmoins d'adopter
un amendement visant deux objectifs
d'une part la rédaction du texte
gagnerait à mieux prendre en compte la
situation spécifique des communes
situées dans un département qui n'est
pas membre du sien d'autre part je
souhaite préserver l'équilibre de la
gouvernance du Cap tout en répondant aux
attentes des élus locaux dont il
convient de renforcer le droit
d'information il faut ainsi me
semble-t-il renforcer l'effectivité
juridique de la proposition de loi de
nos collègues en précisant son champ
d'application en effet les communes
situées sur le territoire des
départements de l'Essonne de la
Seine-et-Marne de Val-d'Oise et des
Yvelines ne bénéficient pas des
prérogatives dont dispose des
départements membres du SSIAP c'est à
dire Paris Hauts-de-Seine Val de marnes
Saint-Denis puisque ces communes ou
leurs intercommunalités de rattachement
ne sont pas liés au sien que par
convention et non à ce titre pas accès
aux organes de gouvernance du SSIAP
en outre la rédaction envisagée par la
proposition de loi permet de manière
très pertinente de faire siéger les
communes qui possèdent une station
d'épuration sur leur territoire ou celle
située à proximité cette dernière notion
appelée à mon sens une clarification en
prenant en compte un critère lié au
risque plutôt qu'un critère géographique
en ce sens le sous-amendement proposé
par notre collègue Jacqueline stage de
brignaud recueille mon assentiment en ce
qui me permet également aux communes qui
ne disposent pas d'une station
d'épuration sur leur territoire de
siéger au sein du conseil
d'administration du ssia dès lors qu'une
telle installation et susceptible de
produire des effets sur la salubrité la
santé et la sécurité publique
directement ou par pollution du milieu
de leur territoire en second lieu il me
semble essentiel de préserver
l'équilibre de la gouvernance du sien
le SSIAP remplit sa mission de manière
satisfaisante pour nos concitoyens
concernés c'est pourquoi il me semble
qu'apporter dès aujourd'hui des
bouleversements conséquents dans sa
gouvernance qui plus est dans le
contexte du déploiement du plan baignade
en vue des Jeux Olympiques 2024 ne
m'apparaît pas au portant or c'est bien
ce à quoi aboutirait la proposition de
loi en prévoyant l'octroi d'une voix
délibérative aux communes siégeant au
sein du conseil d'administration et du
bureau du ssia il me semble donc que
l'objectif poursuivi par les auteurs du
texte trouverait une meilleure mise en
oeuvre par l'octroi d'une simple voix
consultative aux communes cette solution
apporterait une réponse immédiate et
adéquate aux attentes exprimées par les
élus locaux tout en maintenant les
équilibres existants
en troisième lieu je vous propose de
renforcer l'opérationnalité du
dispositif en améliorant l'information
de tous les conseillers municipaux des
communes concernées via à deux
mécanismes distincts
rendant tous les conseillers municipaux
des communes représentées au conseil
d'administration du SSIAP destinataire
de la convocation adressée avant chaque
réunion des documents afférents et des
listes des délibérations qui ont été
examinées en faisant bénéficier
également les conseillers municipaux
d'un droit à l'information sur les
affaires du ssia faisant l'objet d'une
délibération ayant une incidence directe
ou indirecte sur la gestion des
installations de retard traitement des
eaux usées situées sur leur territoire
par ailleurs sur cet enjeu de
l'information des élus locaux je
comprends pleinement l'intention de
notre collègue Marie-Pierre de la
Gontrie dont l'amendement propose la
création d'une conférence des
territoires auprès du Siam cependant je
ne suis pas favorable à cette amendement
dans la mesure où il me semble déjà
satisfait dans les faits puisque
l'article 9 des statuts du SIA prévoit
la réunion annuelle d'une conférence
d'information de l'assainissement de
l'agglomération parisienne regroupant
l'ensemble des élus des collectivités ou
de leur groupement concernés par le
sujet
en outre la création de cette conférence
ne me semble pas être de nature à
résoudre les carences informelles dont
Patti aujourd'hui les élus locaux du
fait d'une gestion trop opaque par le
ssia les sites situés sur leur
territoire pour conclure mon propos je
tiens à souligner que j'ai travaillé en
parfaite coopération avec notre collègue
Martha décidrac dans les laboration de
l'amendement que je vous soumettrai je
la remercie chaleureusement de la
qualité de nos échanges et de notre
collaboration pour formuler des pistes
de solution équilibrées et consensuelles
dans l'intérêt des élus locaux des
communes de la grande couronne
parisienne je vous remercie merci Madame
la rapporteur
buffet madame la sénatrice martad Sidrac
madame la rapporteur Catherine
belleretti mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs nous sommes aujourd'hui réunis
en commission des lois pour étudier une
proposition de loi de la sénatrice
Martin de Sidrac visant à renforcer la
voie des élus locaux au sein du service
public de l'assainissement francilien le
SSIAP
le syndicat inter départemental pour
l'assainissement de l'agglomération
parisienne ce SSIAP créée en 1970 comme
vous l'avez dit chargé du transport et
du traitement des eaux usées produite
par l'agglomération parisienne à savoir
de 287 communes rassemblant plus de 9
millions d'habitants le SSIAP est un
établissement public administratif ayant
historiquement pour membre les
départements de Paris des Hauts-de-Seine
de Seine-Saint-Denis et du Val-de-Marne
le conseil d'administration du SSIAP est
ainsi constitué de 33 représentants de
ces quatre départements
par ces missions le SSIAP travaille
toutefois une échelle territoriale plus
large et en particulier dans les
départements de la grande couronne
parisienne c'est la volonté d'être
associé au fonctionnement du SSIAP qui
vous a conduit mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs à présenter la présente
proposition de loi qui vise à prévoir la
présence au conseil d'administration
avec voie des libératives de
représentants des conseils municipaux
des communes accueillant ou situés à
proximité d'une installation gérée par
le SSIAP
ce souhait d'association large des
collectivités au fonctionnement de cette
structure de coopération inter
départementale me semble parfaitement
légitime notamment pour assurer la bonne
information des élus qu'en surviennent
comme cela a pu être le cas sur certains
sites du SSIAP des accidents
d'exploitation vous le savez mais je
promets autant que possible les méthodes
de travail et de gouvernance qui
permettent au niveau local de s'assurer
que les élus locaux sont associés aux
décisions qui sont prises à l'échelle de
leur territoire s'agissant du SSIAP
l'État c'est d'ailleurs montré
particulièrement attentif au cours des
dernières années à renforcer cette
association à la suite d'une mission
conduite par le préfet Godin pour le
compte du préfet de la région
Île-de-France a ainsi été mis en place
une conférence de l'assainissement qui a
précisément pour objectif d'assurer
l'information et l'association des élus
des territoires d'implantation du sien
par ailleurs les commissions de suivi de
sites mises en place autour d'un certain
nombre de sites sont aussi des lieux
d'information et d'échanges qui
associent des collectivités et les élus
qui accueillent en particulier les
stations d'épuration gérées par le sien
votre proposition de loi intervient dans
ce contexte et dans ce cadre et elle
souhaite associer les élus représentant
les communes d'implantation de certaines
usines du SSIAP à la gouvernance de ce
dernier
en l'état du texte initial qui a été
présenté s'il cherche à répondre à cet
objectif parfaitement compréhensible il
présente un certain nombre de fragilités
juridique qui nous semble faire obstacle
à son adoption avant que vous l'amandiez
dans vos propos madame la rapporteur
sur le plan du droit à la proposition
initiale prévoyait en effet que des
représentants de ces communes soient
membres du conseil d'administration du
SSIAP avec voie des libératives sans
pour autant que les communes concernées
soient elles-mêmes membres du syndicat
accepter cette distorsion nous
semblerait déroger lourdement aux règles
qui régissent le fonctionnement de ce
type de structures de coopération qui
prévoit toujours que la participation
aux instances de gouvernance découlent
de l'adhésion de la collectivité au
syndicats ou à l'établissement de
coopération cette règle est saine et
nous avons besoin de la préserver au
demeurant dans le cas particulier du SSP
cela reviendrait à modifier
substantiellement la gouvernance de ce
dernier dont je rappelle qu'il est conçu
pour réunir des départements qui en
petite couronne sont compétents en
matière d'assainissement la
participation aux instances de
gouvernance du SSIAP nous semble ainsi
devoir découler d'abord de l'exercice de
cette compétence sur le périmètre du
syndicat vous l'avez compris le texte
initial n'était pas satisfaisant sur le
plan juridique le texte amendait tel que
vous l'avez présenté madame la sénatrice
c'est elle qui a été repris par Madame
la rapporteur qui prévoit une présence
avec voix consultative pose bien entendu
beaucoup moins de difficultés même si
nous considérons qu'une révision des
statuts du SSIAP pourrait avoir le même
effet je m'en remettrai sur ce point à
votre sagesse
quoi qu'il en soit il me semble
essentiel de trouver les voix et moyen
d'une association effective des élus des
territoires concernés de la grande
couronne au fonctionnement du SSIAP le
préfet de la région Île-de-France je le
sais initier un travail en profondeur
pour parvenir à cet objectif et si il
est d'ailleurs engagé devant vous à le
poursuivre y compris en ouvrant le sujet
et il est et il sait d'ailleurs engagé
pardon devant vous à le poursuivre y
compris en ouvrant le sujet de la
refonte des statues du siècle je reste
bien entendu à l'entière disposition du
Sénat pour assurer le suivi de ce
travail dont je ne doute pas qu'il
permettra de satisfaire la demande de
votre Haute Assemblée
merci Madame la Ministre
de la parole à ceux qui le souhaitent
Monsieur Alain Richard
merci monsieur le Président
je voudrais d'abord
apporter une complément d'information
puisque dans les interventions qui ont
eu lieu jusqu'à présent il n'a pas été
fourni d'explications au fait que les
départements de Paris et de la petite
couronne soit par dérogation par
exception compétent en matière
d'assainissement l'histoire et la
suivante le réseau et les premières
installations d'épuration
j'étais trop loin tout simplement donc
le développement du réseau est des
premières installations les plus rations
qui datent à la période d'avant la
guerre de 1914 a conduit à au constat
double que la Ville de Paris disposait
d'une ingénierie et de ressources
financières lui permettant de conduire
ce projet alors que les communes de
banlieue à l'époque peu peuplées et peu
équipés en été dépourvu et d'autre part
que la législation qui restait en
vigueur la législation d'exception qui
est restée en vigueur jusqu'à la réforme
de 1975 empêché Paris participer à un
syndicat intercommunal
et l'accord a été conclu après la guerre
de 14 entre les conseillers municipaux
de Paris et les élus de la banlieue pour
confier cette mission au département de
la Seine qui donc par exception et à ce
moment-là la notion de compétence
n'était pas aussi arrêtée qu'aujourd'hui
donc ceci c'est fait sans soutien
législatif mais le département de la
Seine a été le maître d'ouvrage le
réalisateur de toutes les grandes
canalisations d'écoulement de la des
eaux usées de la l'agglomération et de
la réalisation des stations d'épurations
laquelle a pris d'ailleurs un temps
considérable si bien que j'ai en
relisant cette histoire pour des raisons
locales je me suis rendu compte que on
avait cessé de faire descendre des eaux
usées dans la scène que au cours des
années 1990
et donc lorsque le département de la
Seine a été dissout par l'effet de la
réforme territoriale de 1964 comme
d'ailleurs pour d'autres missions qu'il
exerçaient à titre intercommunal il a
fallu trouver les systèmes de
substitution et ça a été la création de
ce syndicat de département lesquels on
parle la loi puisque il faut un support
législatif une compétence exceptionnelle
en matière d'assainissement alors que
partout ailleurs cette compétence c'est
celle des communes très généralement et
souvent légalement exercée par les
intercommunalités et donc le l'objet de
la proposition de loi est tout à fait
légitime tout à fait bienvenue puisque
il y a depuis longtemps et
principalement aux abords des grandes
stations d'épuration et la place la plus
importante bien sûr étant celle
d'Achères
des sujets de nuisances et parfois de
risques encore qu'elles soient tout de
même très très éloignée des lieux
d'habitation et donc la formule qui
était proposée par notre collègue Martin
de Sidra présenter des défauts puisque
elle consistait à faire si j'ai dans un
conseil d'administration dont chacun des
membres
représentent 100000 habitants ou plus
des conseillers les représentants de
communes de 10 ou 20 000 habitants ce
qui était déjà un premier sujet et puis
surtout une hétérogénéité puisque ces
communes n'ayant pas de responsabilité
dans la gestion du service public en
question aurait été des espèces de
partenaires anormaux
et comme comme l'ont dit la rapporteur
et la et la ministre il existe déjà mais
simplement à titre d'une initiative du
SSIAP un peu poussée il faut bien le
dire mais un organisme interne qui est
une conférence
d'informations mais qui ne seraient ni
qu'une fois par an donc il y avait
quelque chose à faire
et je vous laisse souligner qu'en
réalité il y a deux dossiers auxquels il
faut remédier le premier c'est donc la
situation des communes riveraines ou des
communes exposées au risque dont nous
allons parler mais il y en a un deuxième
car pour des raisons alors de
développement du service public et de
géographie de l'île de France un grand
nombre de
d'intercommunalité elle responsable elle
compétente en matière d'assainissement
on souhaitait plutôt que de réaliser
leur propre station d'épuration à
proximité se raccorder au réseau
principal du SSIAP et bénéficier des
du travail des stations d'épuration du
SSIAP or ces communes ces
intercommunalités ça s'adapte de 25 ou
30 ans ou 40 pour certaines
n'ont qu'un lien de convention avec le
SSIAP justement du fait de la rigidité
de son statut législatif
et donc ne participe
reçoivent simplement finalement une
information sur ce qualifié le SSIAP en
ce qui concerne des installations dont
ils sont eux utilisateurs et
contributeurs
donc il me semble qu'il est en réalité
deux réformes à faire la première c'est
en effet de consolider le système de
concentration et d'information
dérivera enfin les communes
représentants du riverains et de le
mettre dans la loi et le deuxième c'est
de prévoir dans la loi que les
collectivités
qui sont utilisateurs et financeurs du
service public deviennent
administrateurs elles et ceci
supposerait de transformer donc le SSIAP
de syndicats interdépartemental en
syndicat mixtes mais il faudrait
toujours un équilibre de représentation
puisque naturellement tous ces élus
représentent tout simplement des
redevables
les gens dont les renommer les redevance
de l'assainissement qui sont dans nos
factures d'eau à tous Lorsque nous
sommes résidents de ces zones sont les
contributeurs du service public donc il
me semble qu'il y a matière à une
deuxième initiative législative qui je
crois est préparé par quelques collègues
de l'Assemblée
pour prévoir l'insertion dans le corps
administratif du SSIAP des collectivités
qui sont raccordées au SSIAP il me
semble donc que ce document que nous
allons adopter et simplement un document
d'étapes et sur le fond je voudrais
quand même mettre en garde sur le fait
que le conseil d'administration et donc
un organe décisionnel sur lequel
naturellement il y a du travail
préalable de
commissions de préparatifs mais qui est
un organe assez lourd du fait de
l'importance de ses responsabilités et
que de faire siéger à côté des 33
administrateurs plusieurs dizaines de
représentants de communes qui ne serait
là qu'à titre consultatif serait une
France exception dans tout assemblée
délibérante de collectivités
territoriales aucune de nos
collectivités délibérante quelle que
soit la volonté de concertation des uns
et des autres ne fait siéger sur ces
bons les représentants d'organismes ou
de
personnalité longue morale non membres
non responsable donc je crois que la
dualité avec un conférence d'information
ou de concertation ayant des droits
particuliers un peu sur le modèle de
l'amendement de Marie-Pierre la Gontrie
et donc un système préférable plutôt
qu'un conseil d'administration mixte
avec des délibérants et des consultatifs
et par ailleurs il faudra traiter le
problème des collectivités raccordées
qui elles représentent plus de 2
millions de redevables merci
Goulet
esprits sur ce dossier mais quel est le
budget du ssia parce que mon pauvre
département de l'or n'a pas la même
amplitude mais ça m'intéresse quand même
de savoir quel est le budget en cause
parce que ça peut aussi susciter
certains nombre d'intérêts
alors qui peut apprendre de citrate
alors je n'ai pas les éléments avec moi
mais je répondrai bien évidemment chers
collègues à votre question toutefois je
tiens à rappeler que c'est pas l'objet
en tant que tel le budget n'intervient
pas dans le débat de ce matin oui oui
mais j'y répondrai bien volontiers c'est
juste que je n'ai pas les éléments avec
moi ce matin notre rapporteur là c'est
un budget de 1 milliards
oui monsieur le président
le rapporteur je suis extrêmement
réservé
pour faire suite aux propos du président
Richard
sur
l'initiative je m'en suis entretenu avec
l'auteur de à plusieurs reprises de la
PPL je vois bien les raisons
d'opportunités qui poussent à agir sans
tarder sur le sujet
on est dans un syndicat inter
départemental
suffit que le département des Yvelines
adhère aussi
on est en train de changer comme vient
de le dire le président Richard la
nature d'un syndicat interdépartemental
peut-être Vers un syndicat mixte avec
toutes les les observations qu'il a
exprimé
il n'y a pas d'ailleurs de station de
usée je crois dans l'Essonne en
Seine-et-Marne et dans le Val-d'Oise à
ma connaissance donc on a étendu à ces
départements
en pure forme il y a pas de station de
usées bon il y a des conventions
financières je rentre pas dans le détail
etc etc on va faire rentrer un tas de
gens effectivement avec voix consultatif
pourquoi pas je pense qu'il y a un souci
qui mérite d'être observé mais tout ça
se fait contre la vie du SSIAP sans que
ça a été délibéré
j'aimerais connaître la vie du
département des Yvelines et dans le
cadre d'un syndicat intercommunal inter
départemental pardon donc la loi prévoit
que des départements peuvent s'associer
c'est le cas des Yvelines et à
l'évidence le département pourrait tout
simplement adhérer bon on est dans un
cadre en plus cela a été dit pour la
concertation puisque le SSIAP est
hostile le président a été auditionné le
SIEP est hostile à mon avis il doit pas
y avoir trop de difficultés à discuter
compte tenu de la majorité politique du
siècle aujourd'hui et de
l'opinion du Président
qui diverge assez peu de la majorité du
département des Yvelines donc à mon avis
doit pas y avoir grande difficulté à
trouver les voies du dialogue mais je
pense que on est en train de prendre
une une
route qui est un peu précipitée
qui est d'opportunité et qui risque de
créer de grandes difficultés par
mimétisme sur l'ensemble des syndicats
de la région parce que si on le fait
pour ce syndicat je vois pas pourquoi on
va pas le faire pour les autres
je vois pas pourquoi on va pas le faire
pour les autres et on va regarder très
près associé toutes sortes de gens dans
tous les syndicats et ils sont nombreux
dans la région puisque il y a les grands
syndicats qu'on va qualifier de
métropolitain et que les Franciliens
connaissent mais il y en a une trentaine
d'autres en matière d'eau et on a une
trentaine d'autres en matière de déchets
il y en a une trentaine d'autres en
matière d'assainissement et à ce
moment-là il y a pas de raison qu'on ne
fasse pas rentrer
les représentants des communes
avec voix consultative je ne sais pas
d'ailleurs si ces représentants seront
dans les commissions également avec voix
consultative jusqu'où ira la
consultation de ces représentants
quels seront la suite donnés aux
conventions financières entre le SSIAP
les départements et les communes
concernées et les syndicats
vieillissement qui travaille parce que
il y a pas que le sien et les communes
il y avait également tout un tas
d'autres syndicats qui sont en
convention avec les communes sur le
devenir des terrains puisque comme l'a
rappelé le président Richard il y a une
histoire et les terrains par exemple à
Achères appartiennent à la ville de
Paris ça appartiennent à la ville de
Paris donc il y a quand même tout un tas
de conséquences qui me paraissent pas
avoir été totalement
travaillé et observé c'est la raison
pour laquelle autant je comprends et je
peux même soutenir l'idée qu'il y a une
amélioration à apporter à ce travail
mais peut-être pas de cette façon un peu
rapide précipité et dont on n'a pas
mesuré encore toutes les conséquences
qui restent qui risque d'être assez
importante pour l'ensemble des autres
syndicats dans la région
merci Madame Marie-Pierre la Gontrie
merci monsieur le président
d'abord je voudrais féliciter ceux à qui
revient l'initiative d'avoir décidé
d'échanger de délibéré sur ce texte en
commission en lac parce que je suis
désolé qu'à une heure si matinale nos
collègues qui ne sont pas franciliens
participent à cette à ce travail mais
dans l'hémicycle je dois dire suite
était encore plus
surréaliste reste que
on l'a bien vu le sujet est à la fois
important et le président Marseille
vient de
l'illustrer en indiquant l'effet
collatéral que pourrait avoir la
décision qui serait prise éventuellement
aujourd'hui pour les autres syndicats
qui pourraient être concernés mais ce
n'est pas le sujet du jour alors ce qui
est proposé aujourd'hui au fond c'est
ainsi que moi je l'ai exprimé compris
lors de l'audition du président du Cap
c'est me semble-t-il d'abord une
manifestation de mauvaise humeur c'est à
dire que les collectivités considèrent
que elles ne sont pas assez informées de
ce qui se passe sur leur territoire dès
lors qu'elles ne sont pas dans le
conseil d'administration et là il y a
peut-être une confusion dans le rôle du
Conseil d'Administration et donc on
décidait d'avancer sur ce terrain en
disant puisque c'est comme ça nous
allons entrer au conseil
d'administration la mauvaise humeur des
collectivités elle se comprend il y a
des incidents qui se sont déroulés
elles ne l'ont appris que plus tard le
président du SSIAP nous confiant
d'ailleurs que lui-même ne l'avait pas
appris tout de suite ce qui est un peu
plus inquiétant en termes de de gestion
interne du siècle mais j'ai envie de
dire ça c'est son problème donc on voit
bien le l'origine et là-dessus on ne
peut que la partager après il y a la
réponse qui est faite ici alors
l'amendement de la rapporteur répond et
résout une partie des difficultés du
texte initial l'une
très forte concernant les voix
délibératives l'autre qui était à la
fois le flou de la formulation puisqu'on
parlait de communes se situant à
proximité sans qu'on sache exactement ce
que ça voulait dire juridiquement
parlant qui faisait de membres du bureau
et du conseil d'administration ce qui
normalement enfin moi m'avait appris
quand j'étais jeune que c'était
impossible et qu'il fallait bref donc
sans faire du du Philippe Bas je dirais
que ce texte méritait avait des marges
de progression dans sa rédaction
mais la rapporteur a proposé une
rédaction beaucoup plus stabilisée et de
ce point de vue alors
est-ce qu'on va décider de voter ici
quelque chose qui va créer un objet
juridique inédit c'est à dire mélanger
des départements et des communes faire
que les communes n'auront qu'une voix
consultative et pas de voie délibérative
je n'avais pas ouvert sur les questions
de commission etc etc alors ce sujet a
déjà été abordé ça a été rappelé puisque
le préfet Godin avait été chargé d'une
mission c'est de la télé ce qu'on a
appelé la conférence d'assainissement
moi j'ai appelé la conférence des
territoires mais enfin bref et dont la
rapporteur a rappelé de manière
pertinente que c'était dans les statuts
mais ça ne se réunissait ça ne se
réunissait annuellement
pour notre part pour ma part pardon j'ai
proposé que cette commission soit
instituée par la loi et que de ce fait
elle puisse se réunir beaucoup plus
souvent puisque on voit bien que le
problème d'information n'est pas
davantage résolu par ce qui est proposé
aujourd'hui pourquoi il faut savoir que
le conseil d'administration n'y a pas
enfin le SIAP il n'y a pas que le budget
qui est absolument colossal mais aussi
les rythmes du conseil d'administration
qui se réunit tous les mois
ce qui est enfin nous sions tous enfin
nous avons tous siéger dans des
structures de ce type et le paradoxe
c'est que quand bien même le dernier
incident s'est déroulé dans la nuit du 9
au 10 octobre le conseil
d'administration serait une cellule
innovante donc j'ai envie de dire de
toute façon le sujet de l'information
n'est pas résolu par la partie passion
au conseil d'administration donc on voit
que le sujet je crois que le président
du SSIAP la parfaitement entendu c'est
un il faut associer les communes mieux
les informer les consulter etc etc ça
semble une évidence à fortiori étant
donné l'ampleur géographique de de
l'intervention du ssia puisque 187
communes c'est évidemment c'est
évidemment considérable n'est pas évoqué
d'ailleurs je le notais dans
l'amendement la notion la situation des
interco alors peut-être faudrait-il
y ajouter j'écoutais les explications
des uns des autres peut-être que ça va
de soi dès lors qu'on parle de communes
etc là-dessus je laisse les juristes
savant voilà alors on l'a dit il y a un
sujet de stabilité de la gouvernance
mais vous avez répondu chers collègues
puisque alors vous avez peut-être trouvé
qu'en Île-de-France ou en tout cas à
Paris on est très obsédé par les JO je
vous cache pas que c'est assez vrai
mais que il se trouve que le SSIAP est
impliqué dans les JO alors ça c'est pas
ça saute pas aux yeux immédiatement mais
dans la mesure où vous savez qu'il y
aura des épreuves dans l'eau de la scène
et dans l'eau de la Marne aussi je crois
du coup le SSIAP est concerné par le bon
et que tous et la position de l'État
aussi
sont absolument
comment dire préoccupé que la stabilité
du fonctionnement du ssia perdure j'ai
envie de dire c'est un petit peu court
mais au moins jusqu'à ce que les JO se
soient déroulés bien donc moi j'ai
proposé un amendement qui crée une
conférence donc qui est beaucoup plus
robuste que ce qui est prévu d'ores et
déjà qui me semble en plus répondre à la
difficulté qui a été pointée par la
Richard de différentiel de statut
c'est-à-dire ça va être un peu trapu de
voir dans un conseil d'administration
des gens qui ont le droit de voter et
pas voté vous me direz c'est comme ce
matin puisque les membres qui ne sont
pas membres de la commission n'ont pas
le droit de voter mais je n'en vois pas
beaucoup en même temps donc ça prouve
bien
que quand on a une voix consultative on
est quand même moins impliqué voilà donc
voilà la position que que je défendrai
et que mes collègues de mon groupe
auront la bienveillance de suivre à ce
stade défendre notre notre amendement
sur la conférence que j'ai appelé je
crois conférence des territoires
et puis ensuite même le rapporteur
j'imagine merci monsieur le Président
chers collègues j'entends le l'ensemble
de vos observations je vous en remercie
je vais commencer par remercier madame
la ministre pour sa sagesse j'ai entendu
les remarques
s'agissant du texte initial que j'avais
déposé et bien évidemment vous avez pu
l'observer je les ai entendus puisque
dans mes propres liminaires j'ai rappelé
que
les amendements proposés par notre
rapporteur ainsi que Madame Eustache
brignot ont tout à fait mon je dirais
mon accord si je peux l'exprimer ainsi
puisque ils vont dans le sens de la
clarification de ce qu'est l'objectif
véritable de ce texte pour revenir sur
les critiques qui ont été soulevées par
le président Marseille par Madame de La
Gontrie
je voudrais quand même rappeler une
chose c'est que dans les propos des uns
des autres on parle des commun on parle
des territoires mais les communes et les
territoires sont des espaces avec des
habitants dans mes propos liminaires je
les rappelais également nous les élus
nous nous sommes que les représentants
au fond de ces habitants là dans nos
territoires qui parfois ont de
véritables inquiétudes lorsqu'il se
passe en incident mineur majeur
qu'importe nous sommes quand même
confrontés parfois et notamment je
reparle excusez-moi monsieur le
Président de l'usine de senaval qui a eu
récemment vous l'avez rappelé les uns et
les autres des des
événements des des incidents mineurs ou
majeurs et qui inquiète nos habitants
dans nos territoires donc nous nous
méprenons pas je ne suis pas du tout et
c'est bien pour ça que aujourd'hui le
texte définitif qui j'espère sera
remondée tel qu'il a été proposée par
Madame la rapporteur sera adoptée par ce
que je crois qu'il faut que nous
entendions également cette expression là
qui est nécessaire nécessaire et je
souhaite rassurer le président Marseille
et d'autres collègues qui se sont
exprimés sur le sujet je dirais
technique de la gouvernance j'ai bien
entendu le message et l'inquiétude que
pouvait susciter ma première rédaction
lorsque j'ai demandé que l'on parle de
de pouvoir délibérative des élus locaux
issus des communes ce n'était c'est je
crois que le texte tel que nous vous le
proposons ce matin a été va dans le bon
sens permet de lever cette inquiétude si
en supposant qu'elle subsiste toujours
et ne surtout ne déséquilibre pas les la
gouvernance actuelle puisque j'ai bien
entendu les messages qui dans le cadre
des différents échanges qu'on a eu des
échanges que j'ai eu également avec
Madame la rapporteur donc vraiment moi
je crois qu'aujourd'hui notre rôle c'est
d'entendre les interrogations les
souhaits les les difficultés que peuvent
avoir rencontré nos élus loc
que de des communes donc les mers là on
nous avons décidé d'implantation pour
pouvoir leur octroyer un minimum de
réponse à ce qui véritablement une
demande légitime sans pour autant
vraiment j'insiste là-dessus sans pour
autant déséquilibrer ce qu'est la
gouvernance aujourd'hui du SSIAP qui est
un qui est un syndicat qui n'a pas
vocation en l'état en tout cas pas dans
le cadre de cette PPL a changé ni de
statut ni de contour ni quoi que ce soit
de fond sur sa manière de fonctionner
voilà je j'espère que mes propos ne
seront pas mal compris et permettez-moi
président de rajouter juste un petit mot
parce que le président Marseille a parlé
de précipitation et de rapides décisions
je ne suis pas d'accord avec ces propos
là parce que je vous invite même si vous
le souhaitez à revoir un certain nombre
d'auditions qu'on a pu avoir avec des
ministres précédents ou à plusieurs
reprises j'ai interpellé vos
prédécesseurs la ministre sur ce sujet
du SSIAP et à chaque fois en me
renvoyait sur le texte de loi on me
disait si vous souhaitez répondre madame
la sénatrice à cette préoccupation
émanant de vos territoires il faudra
déposer un texte de loi et cela ne date
pas uniquement de l'événement qui a eu
lieu en octobre voilà bah écoutez chers
collègues je me remets à votre sagesse
et à votre compréhension et je remercie
de nouveau l'ensemble de la commission
des lois et Madame la rapporteur merci
alors même le rapporteur quelques
observations sans doute oui alors
simplement pour pour répondre à Monsieur
Richard votre proposition est pertinente
monsieur Richard mais ce n'est pas
l'objet de la proposition ce serait une
réforme d'ampleur puisque ce serait une
transformer le SSIAP en syndicat mixte
nous ce que nous voulions faire c'est
surtout renforcer l'information et
associer ces communes au fonctionnement
de du texte c'est un texte modéré que
nous voulions mettre en place en ce qui
concerne monsieur Marseille les Yvelines
ne sont pas compétents en matière
d'assainissement ce sont les interco qui
sont compétentes donc il faudrait créer
un syndicat mixte pour répondre et ce
n'est pas le sujet et en ce qui concerne
le SSIAP n'était pas hostile à ce que à
cette voix consultative des communes on
l'a rencontré et
l'idée lui semblait pertinente
c'est un syndicat particulier qui
n'existe pas ailleurs donc il fallait
une réponse particulière et l'objet du
SSIAP ce sont celles qui qui ont un
statut et ce n'est pas un sujet de
compétence mais c'est un sujet lié au
risque
pour madame de La Gontrie il n'y aura
pas d'effet domino car il n'y a pas les
mêmes incidents dans les autres
syndicats
sinon
le cirque est déjà un syndicat
dérogatoire donc la loi elle ne fait que
adapter que s'adapter au fonctionnement
et le SSIAP est prévu par la loi
bien merci même la porteur alors
peut-être rappeler pardon
les intercos alors le sujet c'est
n'était pas celui des interco ce n'est
pas la compétence mais les risques qui
subissent les communes de la grande
couronne
bien merci j'indique on va aborder les
trois amendements enfin en discussion
commune d'ailleurs je rappelle
disposition qui relative à l'application
du texte considère que le périmètre
inclut les dispositions relatives au
modalités de fonctionnement de
l'institution interdépartementale
compétente en matière d'assainissement
collective des eaux usées des
départements de Paris des Hauts-de-Seine
de la Seine-Saint-Denis et du
Val-de-Marne alors nous avons trois
amendements de discussion commune
directement deux amendements et un sous
amendements le numéro 3 de notre
rapporteur le sous amendement numéro 4
et
l'amendement numéro 2 de Madame de La
Gontrie
nous avons discussion commune vous
présenterait même le rapporteur votre
propre amendement même si vous l'avez
déjà fait en réalité et puis également
le sous amendement de Madame stage
Brignoud dont vous avez déjà parlé
d'ailleurs
alors maintenant
alors partageons pleinement l'intention
de l'auteur de la proposition de loi
d'un indispensable renforcement de
l'information des élus quant à la
gestion des sites situés sur leur
territoire et de leur meilleur
association au conseil d'administration
du ssia le présentement propose une
nouvelle rédaction de l'article unique
de la proposition de loi en accord avec
son auteur afin de recentrer le
dispositif sur la représentation au
conseil d'administration du SSIAP des
seules communes remplissant la double
condition d'être situés sur le
territoire du département non membres du
ssia à savoir l'Essonne la
Seine-et-Marne le Val-d'Oise et les
Yvelines et d'avoir sur leur territoire
une station de traitement des eaux usées
exploitée par ce syndicat de confier à
un membre du conseil municipal de
chacune des communes précitées une voix
consultative aux réunions du conseil
d'administration du ssia d'améliorer
l'information de tous les conseils
municipaux des communes ainsi concernés
en leur octroyant d'une part un droit à
l'information sur les affaires faisant
l'objet d'une libération au sein du
SSIAP ayant une incidence directe ou
indirecte sur la gestion des
installations de traitement
situé sur leur territoire et en
prévoyant d'autre part de les rendre
destinataires du droit de la convocation
des documents afférents à celle-ci ainsi
que de la liste des délibérations
examinées par l'institution de procéder
à diverses améliorations rédactionnelles
la rédaction initiale de l'article
unique de la proposition de loi si elle
a le mérite de rappeler l'indispensable
association des élus locaux à la gestion
des sites d'assainissement situés sur
leur territoire en particulier en cas de
crise apparaît insuffisamment
opérationnel et porté notamment le
risque de bouleverser les équilibres de
représentation existant au sein du ssia
le présent amendement en temps ainsi
levé ses difficultés tout en respectant
l'intention de l'auteur de la
proposition de loi
merci alors il est sous-amendé par
Madame stage Brignoud
et défendu et présenté par madame le
rapporteur et Martin donc j'estime qu'il
a été présenté et l'amendement de Madame
de la ganterie qui est également on peut
construire je vais ajouter juste un mot
parce que il a un plus
peut-être je vais vous convaincre c'est
qu'il intègre les départements parce que
la curiosité dans cette affaire c'est
que le département des Yvelines et le
département du Val d'Oise ont pris une
délibération pour indiquer que elle
souhaitait il souhaitait pardon cette
intégration etc etc mais ne figure pas
dans les rédactions proposées c'est
assez logique d'ailleurs parce que du
coup mais la conférence des territoires
que je propose inclut les départements
et donc permettrait du coup de résoudre
aussi la question de l'information des
départements qui le demandait eux-mêmes
et qui serait fort déçu sinon
merci Monsieur Richard
mustal brignot qui a le mérite de
d'apporter une précision sur un fois
l'objectif et le périmètre des communes
qu'il faudrait associer à cette fonction
consultative d'une part je crois qu'il y
a une fragilité juridique dans la
rédaction de ce sous amendement
puisqu'elle parle des communes situées à
proximité de ces stations
ça me paraît être une base légale trop
imprécise pour décider si une
collectivité à titre pour siéger dans
une instance
la deuxième observation que je veux
faire c'est que si on prend comme motif
de participation à cet instant la
proximité d'une installation du SSIAP et
la prévention des risques des incidents
qui ont résultent ceux-ci se pose aussi
pour les communes qui sont dans la
petite couronne et qui ne seront pas
plus représentés et je pense en
particulier à une station importante qui
est en amont de Paris la station qui est
à Bonneuil c'est de bonne mémoire mais
qui doit déborder je crois sur le
territoire de Créteil
et si on veut donner un droit
d'information à ces communes on ne peut
pas dire que parce que un conseiller
départemental du Val-de-Marne qui est
probablement élu d'un autre territoire
siège au conseil d'administration que la
commune a la possibilité de se faire
entendre sur
les risques et les nuisances auxquelles
il est exposée donc il me semble que
dans une phase ultérieure du travail
législatif parce qu'il me semble que il
est premier à un certain avenir
nous nous devrons compléter cette
lacunes
merci Monsieur le Ministre alors je
demande pas aux rapporteur l'avis sur
son amendement évidemment montre
gouvernement ce qu'il en pense ensuite
sur le sous amendement j'imagine un 20h
que c'est un avis favorable
ce moment de Madame stage Briot pardon
oui
sur le sous amendement de madame vous
avez la parole mais il faut qu'on avance
là maintenant président
simplement dans le par rapport à ce que
vient de dire à la Richard justement
Jacqueline le stage Brignoud a voulu
remplacer les termes comme une situation
à proximité pour le préciser mais je
dois dire que la rédaction lorsque on
parle de commune
comment dire lorsque l'exploitation
d'une station est susceptible de
produire des effets sur la salubrité et
la santé et la sécurité publique
directement ou par pollution du milieu
des guides communes ça veut dire toutes
les communes d'Île-de-France
donc c'est à mon avis je comprends
l'esprit du sésamendement mais je pense
qu'il ne résout pas le problème du tout
alors madame sache Bruno moi je voudrais
juste dire deux mots parce que dans la
réalité moi je suis sénatrice du
Val-d'Oise et j'entends ce qui se passe
dans le Val-d'Oise aujourd'hui les mères
qui aujourd'hui demandent à être
intégrées ce sont les mères des communes
qui sont un peu précisées dans cette
dans cette amendement les maires qui
sont à l'opposé effectivement
complètement à l'aise du départ du Malin
ne sont pas concernés et les demandes
dans la réalité elles viennent des élus
locaux qui sont en proximité donc c'est
pour ça que moi je n'ai pas souhaité
qu'on aille au-delà parce que
l'inquiétude des mères qui sont en
proximité elle est réelle c'est ce qu'il
nous exprime et moi je n'ai jamais
entendu d'autres mères dans le
Val-d'Oise exprimer une inquiétude par
rapport au slap en particulier c'est
pour ça que nous avons limité cet
amendement aux communes à proximité
parce que c'est une réalité
madame la rapporteur sur le sous
amendement de Madame Stach Brignoud vous
avez mis un avis favorable considérant
que une précision rédactionnelle qui
permet d'identifier plus clairement les
communes
en revanche sa rédaction me semble assez
clair pour l'amendement de Madame de La
Gonterie votre avis
une demande de retrait car vous
considérez qu'effectivement il est
satisfait dès lors que votre amendement
sous-amendé sera lui-même voté bien
alors nous allons procéder au vote
madame la ministre pardon et pour la vie
du gouvernement sur l'ensemble de ces
amendements
oui juste en quelques mots
bah autant sur l'amendement 3 donc sur
lequel j'ai
donné la sagesse sur la voie
consultative qui me permet de qui nous
permet de de dire à quel point on est
solidaire de la volonté d'information du
maire qui accueille cette station sur sa
commune
par contre le périmètre est
insuffisamment défini et donc sur le
sous amendement lui-même je les mettrai
un avis défavorable et pour finir je
mettrai un avis favorable sur la
conférence des territoires qui vise bien
évidemment à une plus grande
transparence pour moi il y a deux
temporalités il y a celui de l'urgence
d'information
de la commune qui accueille la station
d'épuration et puis il y a la
temporalité de la refonte des statues
qui a été évoquée à plusieurs titres et
qui nous paraît importantes de
démarrer mais qui elle prendra du temps
merci Madame la Ministre alors avant de
passer au vote je vous rappelle la règle
d'abord le sous amendement ensuite
l'amendement numéro 3 puis enfin
l'amendement numéro 2 je rappelle les
règles des pouvoirs
le pouvoir de Monsieur Le Rue dudier
votre serviteur a le pouvoir de Monsieur
Leroy madame Jourda a le pouvoir de
Monsieur Darnaud
j'indique que
Madame de La Gontrie a le pouvoir de
monsieur Sueur
que Monsieur Didier Marie a le pouvoir
de Monsieur Bourgy et enfin Madame Gatel
a le pouvoir de Monsieur Philippe
bonnecarère madame Goulet a le pouvoir
de Madame lanatetuani et Monsieur
Marseille a le pouvoir de Monsieur de
Bellay et je crois que j'ai informé tout
le monde voilà
bien alors nous procédons au vote je
mets aux voix le sous amendement numéro
4 avec un avis favorable du rapporteur
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
on compte le bien les bras on va compter
qui est contre
levez bien les bras qu'on compte juste
c'est que c'est tout mais bon
14 14 égalité la conséquence c'est qu'il
n'est pas adopté
je mets au voir maintenant l'amendement
numéro 3 non sous amendée qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
donc l'amendement numéro 3 du rapporteur
est avec la sagesse du gouvernement je
l'ai pas rappelé pardon il est donc
adopté et nous en arrivons à
l'amendement numéro 2 de Madame de La
Gontrie qui tombe du fait de la
probation plutôt de l'amendement numéro
3 je vais y arriver voilà
bien sur l'ensemble du texte parce qu'il
y a qu'un seul article on est bien
obligé de le voter quand même
je pense qu'il y aura des ajustements à
faire dans la procédure on peut pas
rajouter ce matin merci Madame la
Ministre merci Madame la rapporteur donc
notre séance est suspendue il nous
reprenons immédiatement dans notre salle
de commission
merci